what oh my god
oh this game is so much worse if they
are holy I didn't even want to play this
game in front of a TV oh my god it's
dark out wait did I just heal myself an
accident it I was gonna need that oh I
don't like that piano
[Music]
this is pretty intense I like em
straight up I'm just gonna have a
shotgun it makes me feel better
this is what VR is all about now okay
okay it's just oh oh okay oh gun it's
just you and me now God Jesus oh okay
I'll just shoot that baby no no no stay
away no please oh my god
I actually I freaking hate this hi
little girl
oh my god
why what do you nothing happened
okay
oh my god no come on don't you - no come
on
oh yeah what we need no no sweetie let's
talk about this talk about it sweetie
sweetheart there's no reason that it's
just an altar what's up that Jesus
Christ me dude oh my god
how about are you dad ah what
no no duck Oh am I out of stamina what
the move oh yeah
bring it yeah Bernal
oh you oh Jesus
fire this is not working
OSE haha burn oh my heart
[Music]